[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
bienvenue à vous tous qui nous suivent
et on va parler d'eux politique avec
cette question a priori incongru
françois hollande se prépare-t-il au
match retour après sa charge contre
emmanuel macron ac où il fait donner sa
garde rapprochée entre les deux
présidents l'ancien et l'actuel la hache
de guerre est bien déterrée autre sujet
de débat l'université le mot sélection
qui paraît décidément bien tabou des
propositions très prudente en la matière
sont remises aujourd'hui à la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur
après l'université l'école l'école où là
où commence ou non la lutte contre le
harcèlement sexuel
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez et
enfin la catalogne avec cette question
face à l'impasse de la situation
l'union européenne doit elle jouer un
rôle de médiateur
on voit tout cela dans un instant avec
vous olivier duhamel
bonjour juristes politologues hauteur de
maquereaux et en même temps coécrit avec
laurent bigorgne et alex bodry et qui
vient de sortir chez plon merci d'être
avec nous soit vous bonjour christophe
de boeck
vous êtes historien vous enseigne à
sciences po vous êtes spécialiste des
pays bas mais aussi peut-être par la
force des choses un peu de la catalogne
il vous êtes membre du conseil
scientifique de la fondapol qui publie
où va la démocratie avec nous également
sylvain courage rédacteur en chef à
l'ops l'ops quitte cette semaine en une
harcèlement sexuel briser le silence
bonjour sylvain et bonjour alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro
figaro où l'on parle tous demain de la
catalogne de l'université de la lutte
contre le harcèlement sexuel et de
politique
évidemment la politique alors la place
de meilleur opposant à emmanuel macron
et l apprendre françois hollande semble
briguer le titre en tout cas lui et ses
amis donnent de la voix profitant du
blues de jean-luc mélenchon et de la
faiblesse de marine le pen
écouter l'un d'eux et pas le moindre
bernard cazeneuve l'ancien premier
ministre et ancien ministre de
l'intérieur c'était ce matin sur europe
1 il y avait un homme qui n'était pas
adam et heure à l'elysée qui était
secrétaire général adjoint qui était en
charge de toutes les questions
budgétaires fiscales économiques qui
s'appelait manuel macron
il y avait comme directeur adjoint du
ministre de l'économie des finances en
charge de la fiscalité des entreprises
un homme de grande qualité qui n'est pas
du tout à l'amateur et pour lequel j'ai
le plus grand respect qui s'appelle
alexis colère ou les parfois l'amnésie
est un moteur de la politique mais moi
je ne suis pas amnésique et je considère
que
surtout lorsqu'on dit tous les jours sur
tous les sujets j'assume il ya des
choses qu'on va pouvoir assumer quand
elles correspondent à une réalité vie
duhamel il est taquin bernard cazeneuve
que nous autres s'ils avec françois
hollande
je pense qu'il n'est pas seulement
acteur je pense que la marque 15 9 qu'on
croyait se voir s'éloigner de la
politique qui décide pas se représenter
aux élections législatives et de laisser
la place à cherbourg qui reprend un
travail d'avocat qui écrit un livre sur
son passage à matignon en vérité c'est
bernard cazeneuve qui revient à vitesse
grand v est autant un retour de françois
hollande me semble personnellement
impossible pour deux raisons la première
c'est que quand même même si elles
devaient s'atténuer elle s'atténuera
rétrospectivement d'impopularité a été
trop grande et deuxièmement parce que
nous vivons des temps où les retours ne
se font plus pas déjà giscard n'y est
pas arrivé dans aucune démocratie au
monde quelqu'un qui a été battue ou qui
a été obligé de renoncer ne peut se
représenter en revanche entre mélenchon
blues ou pas et macron il ya quand même
un tel espace que forcément quelque
chose va remettre de ce parti socialiste
moribond et devra s'incarner alors
écoutez si vous m'invitez mettons dans
un an ou deux ans vous verrez la place
de bernard le coq tout ou pas aller vite
parce que dans cet acquis dryades
il ya une part politiques dont une par
les oliviers et qui est essentielle mais
aussi une part personnelle c'est-à-dire
comme disent les jeunes 15/09 volant 10
on vénère l'autre les a roulés dans la
farine leur a donné des leçons et
maintenant il se dit lui renvoie macron
les traites de les renvoie dans le
quand des fainéants et des débats var
est donc bon donc il ya un côté on règle
des comptes parce que on s'est fait
trahir et rouler dans la farine
ça compte aussi en politique donc ça
c'est une première partie des choses et
puis la partie plus politique
je suis d'accord avec olivier quand il
dit que le retour de françois hollande
est tout à fait improbable est sans
doute impossible
ça n'est pas parce que nous nous disons
c'est que françois hollande le pense et
et est donc mal j'ai quand même le
sentiment qu aussi curieux que cela
puisse paraître qui se dit que il ya un
espace ça c'est vrai il ya un espace
entre macron et et mélenchon il n'y a
personne aujourd'hui au parti socialiste
occuper cet espace et qui va déjà
commencer à l'occuper médiatiquement et
peut-être de mal occupé politiquement
verra pas convaincu françois hollande de
son impopularité fonctionnement à lille
a quitté le pouvoir en se disant je me
démène mais l'histoire me rendra justice
et la jarre est apolitique non non
jamais non il n'a jamais dit qu'il
prenait sa retraite de la politique mais
il espérait surtout que l'histoire est
assez rapidement allé lui rendre justice
pour tout ce qu'ils avaient fait d'utile
pour le pays
laquelle le retour de la croissance
économique à septembre de réformes et au
lieu de ça ils voient un de ses anciens
obligé qui prend le pouvoir et qui ne
cesse de lui cogner dessus et qui le
renvoie à ses insuffisances donc
effectivement ça le fait tourner en
bourrique injuste parce très sûr que
françois hollande et intérêts à
manifester aussi ouvertement son
agacement parce que pour emmanuel macron
c'est un avantage que françois hollande
aujourd'hui voilà parce qu'ils se
démarquent mieux de lui et quelque part
il fait il fait passer hollande pour
quelqu'un qui était gris gris qui m'ont
christophe d'europe
oui mais moi je m'intéresse aussi
beaucoup la rhétorique politique à
sciences po et là moi ce qui m'a frappée
c'était en effet la manière magnifique
rétorsion rhétorique s'appelle de 15,9
sur le terme d' amateur qui l'a renvoyé
à l'expéditeur en quelque sorte et
d'autre part ce qui m'a aussi frappé
c'est toujours ce thème du bilan et
alors je trouve que là c'est un peu
curieux de voir bernard cazeneuve dire
c'est quand même scandaleux et c'est le
fait de critiquer son prédécesseur alors
que quand même bien lire françois
hollande n'a fait que ça pendant cinq
ans de critiquer son prédécesseur et ce
matin encore
bernard cazeneuve a rappelé le mauvais
le bilan de nicolas sarkozy oui on est
au delà
au delà de la tombe hollande n'était pas
ministre sarkozyste ou non non mais ce
que je parle de faits de façon suspecte
c'est vrai mais le fait de ceux de ce2
l'argument je veux dire l'argument de
dire c'est pas bien de dire du mal de du
bilan précédent était un argument qui
lui fit lui 6ème art voilà ce que
déclare cette fameuse histoire de la
taxe sur les trois consistant oui sur
les dividendes dont macron être
gouvernement dise c'est une sottise
absolue de françois hollande ferait
fontaine 10 milliards kim d'amateurisme
qui m'a coûté des milliards aux finances
de l'état
c'est vrai que ça va coûter des
milliards aux finances de l'état
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils font là rembourser
aux entreprises le trop perçu
mais c'est bien aussi la caserne a
parfaitement raison de dire que à
l'époque où cette taxe a été inventé
macron était secrétaire comme la nôtre
mettewie l'aude ne pas de page sur les
10 milliards je suis très surpris de
personne ne critique le conseil
constitutionnel d'avoir pris une
décision aussi responsable car bien
entendu il devait déclarer cet axe
inconstitutionnelle mais ils avaient
tous les moyens pour en limiter les
effets catastrophiques puisque ces lots
conséquents ciel qui définit les effets
d'entente décision il peut être n ya qu
il développe mais oui ça changeait tout
et c'est très étonnant qu'il ait été
aussi loin dans une décision
conséquences catastrophiques pour nos
finances publiques et que personne ne
lui en fin de grille m
oui mais vous êtes spécialiste de ce
sujet mais attention la ramène il ya
quand même une décision de la cour
européenne
oui mais en fait que les sans problème
de le faire à partir de voir le
conseiller
il faut retenir qu'il faut tenir convié
les conseils et d un petit peu coincé
juridiquement houssin on va juste
écouter edouard philippe parce que dans
la série des amabilités échangées
il a sa part aussi j'aimerais que ceux
qui aujourd'hui à dix mille kilomètres
alors qu'ils ne se sont pas présentés
aux élections pour défendre leur bilan
commente de façon acide et acerbe ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui pour réparer le
pays près d'une certaine forme
d'humilité sur ce qu'ils ont fait hier
et sur les responsabilités qu'ils ont
dans les dérèglements de l'économie
française ça vaut pour l'ancien
président de la pub je le dis sans
aucune animosité vérité
décidément tous les termes amateurisme
ping pong mais dans un genre voisins
mais qui concerne cette fois les jupes
east 17 face à phrase de virginie
calmels dans un papier du figaro dia de
jeu où elle dit ceux qui ont fait perdre
alain juppé elle elle pense à edouard
philippe et jean boyer sont aujourd'hui
ceux qui se retrouvent au gouvernement
et à d'autres de dos dans tous les cas
on règle des comptes par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé d'abord c'est un peu la
loi dure alors rien j'ai un qui n'est
pas sur ce registre c'est le dg de lvmh
bernard arnault
vous allez voir pas sûr qu'ils rendent
service à emmanuel macron on écoute
depuis que président macro et d'arrivée
l église est l'image de la france et des
entreprises françaises a complètement
changé dans le monde quand j'allais en
angleterre ou aux états unis à deux ans
on avait tendance à me plains cher
monsieur mais comment vous pouvez vivre
dans un pays pareil les impôts n'arrête
pas d'augmenter ou les entrepreneurs
sont honnis et maintenant ça a
complètement changé toutes les mesures
annoncées et mises en oeuvre par le
président la république vont attirer en
france beaucoup d'investissements que ça
va avoir un effet positif sur l'emploi
en pleine polémique sur le président des
riches
c'est pas forcément très adroit disons
qu'à cause de la personne et des
bizarreries de notre pays mais sur le
fond ce qu'il dit est limite c'est ce
que macro aurait dû dire un peu plus
fortement dans son intervention
télévisée au lieu de nous parler de
corde et qui était quand même un truc je
vous présenterez quelqu'un qui pense que
si bernard arnault s'enrichit
considérablement c'est excellent pour
lui parce qu'il va avoir plus d'argent
s'il est de la classe moyenne à falgos
populaire vous ne trouverez pas bon en
revanche c'est hilton le fond de la lune
pour investir croissance emploi alors
c'est pas parce que c'est bien arnaud
qu'il dit que c'est faux donc vous avez
raison dans notre pays en effet si
bernard ado dit que macro et bien ça
veut dire que macro et mal mais c'est
quand même 2 0 on est parent s'écoute
ailleurs alexis non
malgré tout quand il s'agit de savoir
enfin quand on parle de création
d'emplois de croissance et de prospérité
après tout bernard l'autre plus mal
passé bon voilà oui et puis la contre
argumentation et les menaces il est
encore là contre l'argumentation été
facile parce que à chaque fois
emmanuel macron peut dire mais justement
justement je suis sorti de ce
gouvernement
justement si je sais bien que c'était
j'étais pas d'accord sinon je me serais
pas présenté etc etc
il peut tout à fait mettre en scène le
désaccord historique qu'il a eu avec ce
gouvernement et notamment sur les 3 %
rappeler que c'est un amendement
parlementaire par exemple alors ça ne
déplaît pas à la droite et tout ça
déplaît fortement à la gauche et il ya
un moment où peut-être qu'il faut en
effet que penser assez bons pour côté
droit soyons un peu côté haut je ne sais
pas du tout ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce que c'est pas du tout ce que fait
maintenant quand on voit dans son conte
son intervention sur la sécurité
l'immigration le terrorisme on compta il
en remet à droite mais je pense que son
calcul c'est de se dire avec les
premières mesures économiques je plais à
la droite mais aux catégories
supérieures à la bourgeoisie aux riches
aux deux mais riche et sans et
maintenant je vais pas m'adresser à la
gauche même adressé aux catégories
populaires et donc là dessus je fais de
la fermeté en matière de sécurité
d'immigration et de terrorisme
donc il essaie de ne pas s'inscrire dans
les clivages politiques de s'inscrire
dans les petits vaches sociologie son
acoustique au départ existe presque
question qu'il faut que tu sois regard
de gauche voudrait savoir que les
classes sociales et voilà donc c'est son
côté mars au brésil
c'est à dire je fais une politique
économique de droite et comme ça je
plais à braiser et je fais une politique
sécuritaire de droite parce que
président dira comme ça que tu paies au
peuple voilà alors je vais vous soumet
la réflexion d'evelyne lamboeuf qui nous
dit les deux donc macro hollande sont
identiques il n'ya que lâche qui
diffèrent n'oublions pas que mâcon et
ministre d'hollande il participait au
conseil des ministres a prouvé sa
politique ce jeune aux dents longues
devrait se faire examiner je crains
qu'ils soient atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer
un autre en tout cas qui lui est
élogieux je ne vous dirai pas son nom
écouter juste cette description qui fait
d'emmanuel macron il parle donc du
président comme de gaulle il a une
vision comme pompidou c'est un homme de
lettres comme giscard un inspecteur des
finances comme mitterrand un homme
d'histoire comme chirac il est
empathique et comme sarkozy
il est hyper énergique et enfin comme
hollande il a de l'humour qui est
l'auteur de ce pays de bray mais c'est
pas lui c'est pas tout à fait ça c'était
ce matin dans un quotidien qui n'est pas
figaro non c'est richard ferrand qui
était interviewé
c'est un tirage de très grande qualité
oui on est entre le roi soleil et la
corée du nord
dans ces cas précis c'est castaner mais
l'affairé là je pense que là c'est
peut-être plus dangereux ce genre de
frasques ce qu'a dit le président de
lvmh en fait c'est à dire des jeux tirés
c'est plus dangereux pour le président
et ses problèmes des courtisans
c'est-à-dire et malheureusement ça c est
pas lié à emmanuel macron c'est lié au
pouvoir avec un grand p et celia nos
tradition monarchique et là on voit trop
on entend trop de ce genre de phrase et
la joie que même si c'est très bien
écrit d'ailleurs il faut lui reconnaître
ça je crois que ça peut desserrer le
président d'abord en le coupant encore
un peu plus de des protestations et
d'autre part en créant oui une sorte
c'est ça une sorte de bulle dans
laquelle il n'entendrait plus alors que
déjà on veut pas dire que aymen macron
soit il perd sensible à ce qu'on pense
de lui et un accord très ouverts à ce
genre d y avait les muscs un destin
aussi qui a dit à la télévision radio
télévision suisse qu'il admirait la
vitalité des manuels malgré qu'ils
estimaient même qu'il a fait c'est
parfois preuve de culot et qu'ils
avaient des points communs explique mais
ces mêmes mais il ya un fond de vérité
un fonds d le corps central mais les
français sur trois
et et la modernisation et la
modernisation quand même geste car ça a
été un grand coup de moderne il faut lui
souhaiter un maquereau que s'accentuent
pas fait parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que jusqu'à a commencé
s'est coupé de son camp en se disant
tout je vais séduire le camp d'en face
ça a mal fini ce prix c'est à dire si ce
précédent là s'applique est à mâcon ça
finira mal pour ma campagne mais aussi
par un souper un peu caricatural mais
non c'est pas ça c'est je suis pas sûr
que la clé de l'échec de jusqu'à reçoit
l'as l'accueil décès jusqu'à c'est
plutôt dans ce qu'on évoquait de la
coupure c'est plutôt jean pierre qui
nous livre aussi cette question macron
s'exonère de son passage au ministère
des finances où il a bradé un certain
nombre d'entreprises
n'at-il pas lui aussi des comptes à
rendre dans sa particulièrement aux
insectes et la paix ne sort plus parce
que c'est tellement technique et je
pense que non l'argument de maquereaux
était d'ailleurs excédent se trouvait là
dessus sur ce point au moins pendant son
intervention s'est on peut pas à la fois
dire c'est affreux on aux entreprises
partent à l'étranger et à bâle capitale
en france jouer au moment où c'est pas
le problème des français le bilan de
mâcon quand amy devenir connu c'est même
pas le problème des français qu'est-ce
qui est ce qu'il est un grave qui est
amnésique pour être des français c'est
ce qui fait aujourd'hui finalement son
élection fait de lui un autre homme par
définition est ce qui fait ce qu'il fait
va réussir ou pas c'est ça la question
qui se pose alors justement ce qu'il
fait pour l'université on va en parler
on ne parle plus de sélections pour le
moment le terme de prérequis fait figure
de gros mots après trois mois de
brainstorming des propositions sont
russes remise en ce moment à la mise de
l'enseignement supérieur elles sont
d'une prudence extrême alors le
gouvernement est il en train de reculer
sur un sujet majeur qui rentre à
l'université et pour y faire quoi
c'est la preuve que le gouvernement ne
tient pas ses engagements cette reculade
qui s'annonce sur la sélection
d'université écoutez la
je dirais que je l'avais dit d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau il faut faire très
attention avec le monde universitaire
parce que c'est un peu une chaudron
bouillant et je crois que emmanuel
macron l'a peut-être se dit que bon même
si vous vous rire tous les fronts à la
fois c'est peut-être pas la peine
d'ouvrir celui-ci tout de suite entre
les apl la propagande de mélenchon dans
les universités la frustration liée à
l'échec universitaire on va en parler je
pense c'est à mon avis c'est une
population qui est beaucoup plus
susceptibles de bouger
est ce que je veux dire quand il s'en
méfie que le monde ouvrier c'est une
information qui peut passer pour une
victime si jamais voilà la politique les
agressent trouvera et allemand et puis
c'est vrai que c'est aussi une
inquiétude pour les familles ça touche
pas que les étudiants donc c'est un
sujet très délicat ils ont eu des
signaux quand même une certaine angoisse
voire d'une mobilisation peut-être
qu'ils pouvaient intervenir donc ils
sont prudents mais ce ne sont que ce
n'est qu'un rapport les arbitrages
convoi induites dans un mois vous
proposant on va continuer d'en parler
mais je propose d'écouter justement sur
le sujet jeunesse dans la rue ou pas
françois ruffin député de la france
insoumise
l'histoire est jamais écrite d'avancé
qu'on sait pas ce qui peut se passer
on sait pas ce qui peut se passer dans
les facs voilà mes jeux et je veux moi
je veux surtout by antho fake c'est à
dire vous conseille que dans mais je
sais pas moi je me suis je veux surtout
m'applique à ne pas être un prophète
je ne suis pas un prophète pour dire
regardez ça va être la révolution parce
que je suis sceptique mais je veux pas
être prophète en sens inverse en disant
il ya rien qui va se passer
j'en sais rien mais qui vivra verra
alexis il se garde bien cependant c'est
effectivement françois ruffin mais en
même temps que je veux dire on nous
avait dit que ça l'exposer dans la rue
que les syndicats que si on l'a pas vu
on n'a pas eu là on nous dit les
étudiants bon oui je veux bien que ce
soit toujours explosif les étudiants
n'empêche que si on ne fait rien
qu'est-ce qui se passera à la prochaine
rentrée
c'est qu'on aura des centaines et des
milliers d'étudiants qui vous laissent
s'entasser dans des facultés des
étudiants qui sortent de l qui vont
aller en fac de médecine où ils ont zéro
chance sur cent par 0,1
il suffit par laquelle président de
paris descartes il vous dit
statistiquement c'est pas un sur cent de
ces zéros sur 100 qui venant de l
réussir peut réussir l'examen de
médecine donc il ya un moment
bon
excusez tant qu'on veut mais c'est pas
rendre service aux étudiants que de leur
dire ouais année en médecine parce que
vous avez fait un pronostic emmanuel
macron va tenir là dessus où j'en sais
rien ce qui est sûr c'est que la
l'effective mans les conclusions sont
très présentes évidemment on réunit des
syndicats autour d'une table syndicat
étudiant les syndicats prof les
précédents universités qui veulent que
ça change parce que sinon c'est le
tirage au sort qui t'aime et absurde
donc le consensus qui souhaite un
consensus en retrait après il ya eu des
consultations sur le droit du travail
l'idée c'était qu'il fallait pas y
toucher puis macro il ya quand même
toucher donc en face et ça me semble
encore tôt pour dire qui va reculer
j'espère qu'il le fera pas il fera entre
le tirage au sort et la sélection il ya
des solutions qui consiste à dire à ce
que quelque chose soit proposé à
quelqu'un mais pas forcément ce qu'ils
demandent c'est très compliqué puisque
vous avez d'un quand vous faites de la
politique vous avez d'un côté les
mesures qu'il est vraiment de penser
nécessaire de prendre pour le pays
et vous pensez qu'il est nécessaire si
vous pensez d'instaurer de la sélection
à l'entrée à l'université bas il faut
instaurer de l'interaction entre les
universités et dans le côté quand vous
faites de la politique vous n'êtes pas
obligé non plus d'être totalement
masochistes et foncer dans le mur en
klaxonnant
donc vous n'êtes pas absolument obligé
30 août les mesures qui ont été prises
pour les collectivités locales pour être
sûrs de perdre des élections
sénatoriales au maximum vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'avoir une manière de faire la
réforme de liesse f qui met à peu près
tout le monde contre vous et vous n'êtes
pas obligé non plus de se dire
maintenant je vais essayer de mettre la
maison dans la rue parce que comme ils
n'y vont pas pour le code de travail si
ça chauffe avec des étudiants ce sera
mieux
donc vous pouvez pour des raisons de
survie politique différé atténuer est
tempérée en tout cas à leur place c'est
ce que je ferais et braisé dirais que je
ne fais rien il n'aurait pas
complètement tort je ferai un peu mais
pas tout ce qu'il veut la porte unités
contre le fond voilà alors justement
merouane mais hadji qui nous a rejoint
va nous dire peut-être pourquoi la
crainte des étudiants dans la rue n'est
pas aussi élevé que ça merouane d'après
ce que vous avez pu voir sur les réseaux
sociaux
finalement les étudiants ils sont pas
totalement hostile à ces sélections sont
plutôt majoritairement pour un pur on a
posé la question d'abord sur lefigaro.fr
et 91 % de nos internautes sont pour
la sélection à l'entrée de l'université
sur onze mille votants et sur twitter on
a aussi posé la question on est un peu
moins de personnes 700 votants mais 65%
sont quand même pour alors hormis ceux
qui demandent à corser l'épreuve du bac
ou qui demande des conseillers
d'orientation plus régulier on a ce
qu'ils nous disent comme bunch sur
lefigaro.fr cela existe déjà pour les
classes prépas aux grandes écoles puis
au moment d'entrer dans ses grandes
écoles c'est le meilleur moyen pour
avoir les meilleurs élèves dans chaque
filière on a aussi l'internaute
non mais sérieusement le nom donne déjà
le ton à l'entrée en licence et en
master 1 éventuellement il n'est pas
logique d'admettre des gens qui n'ont
pas le niveau
tout comme il n'est pas logique de
donner un master 1 et de refuser un
étudiant en master 2 soit on est
qualifiés pour la suite cela ne devrait
pas voir son nom
on a un capital biceps cette fois sur
twitter
qui nous dit il faut aussi débloquer des
places pour les autres voies et mettre
dans la tête des profs qu'il n'y a pas
que la fac pour réussir dans la vie
la justice encore un nom évocateur il y
a trop de jeunes qui s'inscrivent à la
fac et ne terminent pas leur année alors
que d'autres voudraient y poursuivre
leurs études et non pas la possibilité
d'y entrer dans certaines filières la
mention au bac devrait déterminer
l'entrée est à noter qu'une minorité
quand même de nos internautes sont
contre et on leur donne la parole
on a l'aval 57 qui nous dit qu'ils nous
dit pardon je suis contre comme il y a
trente ans l'université est un lieu de
savoir un moyen égalitaire pour avoir la
chance d'obtenir un diplôme avec des
études plus longues
la sélection peut se faire à l'entrée de
cette de la licence pour définir et
parcours universitaire mais pas avant et
en a que les bretons qui ont dit non car
je ne jouais que 1 2 3 car je n'aurais
jamais été sélectionné au vu de mon
parcours collèges lycées et pourtant je
sors 2e de ma promo de dfs alors moi je
suis né dans les années 90 si j'ai dû
rechercher ce que c'était le dfs
diplôme d'études supérieures
spécialisées c'est l'équivalent au
master 2 aujourd'hui je ne trompe pas
olivier duhamel depuis la réforme de
2003 et je termine avec margin qui nous
dit qu'il faut plutôt créer plus de
places à l'université si les étudiants
n'ont pas le niveau
si au lycée qu'il faut commencer à
trouver les solutions et par ricochet au
collège
qu'en pensez-vous odier duhamel est ce
que il faut commencer à dénouer le noeud
de la fac des locaux laissent voir dès
la primaire non je pense que des gens
qui vous répondent sont comme beaucoup
de français bien qu'ils soient jeunes et
c'est ni base s'appelle not in my
backyard c'est à dire que remet pour la
sélection mais de préférence pour les
autres mois pour soi moi si je fais là à
l'entrée de sciences po un test sur est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre la
section aviron qui sont pour la
sélection ils ont réussi la sélection
après il veut faire accepter par la
masse des étudiants d'autres choses et
puis le mot est très ambigu parce que
aujourd'hui le baccalauréat
c'est un diplôme d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur le problème
donc c est ce que ça donne le droit
d'aller où on veut c'est impossible
est-ce que ça doit empêcher d'aller
quelque part c'est ça la difficulté mais
les fonds à des fins les voeux apb se
font avant d'avoir le bac
oui j'entends bien mais on ne peut pas
satisfaire tous les voeux en revanche
trouver une place l'idéal évidemment ce
serait quand même de trouver des places
qui correspondent à peu près au pré
orientation possible avec ensuite des
barrières pour pouvoir changer corriger
si on bouge presque idéalement étant
donné ce qui est de ne pas présider
allemand il faudrait une propédeutique
pour tout le monde parce qu'il est
allemand une propédeutique ça veut dire
qu'ils avaient à nouveau dans laquelle
oreille sur la chose à sa large si j'ai
bien compris des syndicats étudiants
entre sont comme ça renchérit la dure ça
renchérit c'est par ailleurs ça serait
pas pour tout le monde donc ça serait ça
serait inégalitaire puisqu'il y aurait
les très bons qui aurait directement les
autres qu'ils feraient une année de plus
et donc les syndicats l'a pas davantage
pour y mêler
alors contrairement à ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure évidemment je sais pas
contrairement c'est un bémol les
syndicats est en tout cas les cas les
plus durs sont beaucoup moins puissant
qu'avant oui oui mais c'est pendant un
déclin c'est pour ça que tu es moins que
ce qu'elle devait et pour avancer pour
ça que ses discussions avec les
syndicats
c'est vrai
dans le domaine de l'entreprise c'est
vrai aussi dans le maine de l'université
ne sont pas forcément représentatifs de
l'unss du point de vue des salariés
pendant l'entreprise et des étudiants
mais elles ont deux intérêts le premier
s'est elle atténue la l'hostilité des
syndicats parce qu'on aime bien être
respecté et même bien être écoutés on se
dit être heureux et c'est la moindre des
choses et la deuxième c'est qu'elles
aident à construire des divisions entre
les seins des biens et on l'a bien vu
sur le code du travail et on pourrait le
voir sur le mode étudiants et là ça
c'est un des trucs sur lesquelles l'un
des domaines dans lesquels il est assez
doué macro et s'il fait ses premiers pas
comme il a divisé la droite comme il a
divisé les indications code du travail
travail pour essayer sur nos sujets et
par ailleurs nous on parle de sélection
pour aller vite pour être plus tranchant
mais macro n'a jamais parlé de ces
élections et parlent de pré requis et la
campagne il a parlé en relation un peu
plus qualitative
alors en fait on veut pas prononcer le
mot car les r10 fille voilà le mot
sélection n'est jamais prononcé
et c'est vrai qu'entre le pré requis et
l'orientation très incitative il ya
entre l'orientation et je te prends où
rien n'est pas une ambition il ya vu un
sondage fait récemment c'est exactement
pour le figaro étudiant qui disait que
80 pourront avoir les chiffres
apparaître à l'écran 80 % des jeunes
sont favorables à l'instauration de
prérequis c'était au pré requis et 61%
d'entre eux sont favorables à la
sélection sur dossier
c'est très encourageant
mais bon ne sous-estimons pas la force
des protestataires il même minoritaire
on le sait depuis longtemps en france
quand même et on connaît aussi la force
de notre hypocrisie d'un système qui en
effet dual très sélectif hyper sélectifs
dans certaines filières il est bien
placé pour le savoir
sur pau et d'autre part très très on va
dire démagogique il faut bien dire sur
l'ensemble du champ universitaire tous
les sondages montrent que les français
acceptent largement le principe l'idée
d'une sélection à l'entrée de
l'université je pense que c'est là
dessus que que le gouvernement
s'appuiera utilement nous
publié un sondage de la semaine
prochaine qui confirmerait fait
attention à tous les français disent que
de très très loin la meilleure chaîne de
télévision c ar t il son propre gardien
et pour prolonger je vous invite à
regarder le figaro live un focus sur
cette question là sur le site du figaro
et figaro lie la lutte contre le
harcèlement ça commence à l'école la
sphère harvey weinstein doit-elle être
enseignée dès la cour de récréation le
respect du sexe opposé ça prend certes
dès le plus jeune âge mais doit-il être
inculquée par les profs par la famille
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france a son idée sur la
question
on l'écouté elle était l'invitée de
france info hier soir je pense qu'il ya
un sujet c'est aussi l'éducation des
garçons pardon excusez moi et la région
ile de france va prendre ça passe le
sujet dans ce sujet et nous ferons avec
le centre hubertine auclert qui est qui
est le bras armé de l'île de france sur
ces questions de de sexisme d'égalité
homme femme
nous allons travailler sur la relation
des adolescents entre parce
qu'aujourd'hui on il semble que c'est
dès l'adolescence que commence à se
prendre des modes de relation
extrêmement voilà d'un autre âge on va
écouter également le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
lui il dit que c'est vraiment du domaine
de la vie quotidienne cette notion
d'égalité entre les sexes
on l'écouté ce matin sur rtl c'est du
domaine de la vie quotidienne c'est
comme la lutte contre le harcèlement
dont je reparlerai dans les temps
prochains c'est des choses qu'on doit
faire comme monsieur jourdain faisait de
la prose c'est-à-dire est vigilant sur
les questions ce n'est pas nécessaire de
faire un cours sur l'égalité garçons
filles il est nécessaire d'être vigilant
sur les comportements du quotidien sur
le respect des uns par rapport aux
autres donc pour moi ça fait partie de
ce respect d'autrui qui est au coeur de
la mission déconne les gricole transmet
des savoirs nous en parlons ce matin
quand nos ballons des mathématiques elle
transmet aussi des valeurs et ces
valeurs peuvent se résumer en respecter
autrui
ça inclut évidemment le respect des
filles par libération
c'est encore une mission pour l'école
missions trop oui j'ai toujours un petit
peu méfiante un petit peu comme le
ministre un peu méfiant compteur dit
c'est à l'école de 1,2 faire tout en
effet commençons d'abord par apprendre
les maths lecture écriture mais là il a
bien raison
dans le cadre du respect d'autrui qui à
mon avis fondamentale il faut absolument
insérer cette dimension je dirais du
genre comme il est aujourd'hui plutôt
d'ailleurs et là je crois que le
ministre comme sur d'autres sujets fait
preuve d'un bon sens qui lui aussi va
convaincre pas mal de français alexis ça
soulève la question la mixité où c'est
un autre sujet monnet ça notre sujet ce
même si c'est cette question peut
exister par ailleurs d'abord je crois
que comme pour toutes ces questions là
cette éducation c'est d'abord comme les
familles le travail avant de parler
d'école même parler de même parler des
familles le nouveau duc et les enfants
et les familles l'école c'est quand même
d'abord le savoir et l'instruction après
l'école peut aussi et doit être un 3e 62
comportement ce que ce côté cours de
morale à répétition on va expliquer à
des garçons qui ricanent qu'il faut
respecter les filles je ne suis pas
absolument sûr que ce soit efficace ne
pas dire faut pas le faire du tout mais
je pense que on les voit tout mais on
leur fait ça sur l'environnement le tri
sélectif comme ça il voit passer ça ils
voient ils écoutent et y rigole bon à
revoir j'ai des trucs dans l'école on
doit pas laisser passer ça fait des
années que dans tous les rapports le
rapport au baiia combien temps plus de
dix ans on voyait dans les classes
un certain nombre de comportements des
garçons visas et des filles les filles
obligés de s'habiller comme des sacs
sinon elles sont font traiter pardon du
mot mais de pétasses donc ça à d'autres
choses et voir d'autres choses et aider
que des comportements qui sont qui sont
vraiment là but du harcèlement violences
à les profs devraient pas aider les
conseillers d'éducation devrait pas le
laisser passer ça ça me paraît plus
important que de fins fameux prêts plus
nécessaire donc tout cas dans l'immédiat
que de faire de faire une énième cours
de morale sylvain courage
oui non c'est logique une drôlerie comme
le ministre attaque ça parle de
l'universalisme
finalement c'est le respect de l'autre
qui inclut le respect du sexe opposé
dans les écoles normalement ça doit pas
vraiment être le lieu numéro un où on
traite ces sujets là en revanche qu'on
commence à le faire très jeune ça c'est
important je pense que
que l'on soit attentif à ça dès les
toutes petites classes parce que l'on
parlait plutôt du lycée du collège c'est
ça me paraît être une bonne chose parce
que c'est quand même dans le rapport
entre les centre-villes sexe ça se joue
beaucoup au niveau du primaire
duhamel je pense que les féministes les
plus durs que je veux dire qu'il faut
pas que je viens d'être souvent sur le
plateau parce que je me fais contaminés
mais je suis assez d'accord pour dire
que pour le principal c'est le
comportement et puis je n'aime pas un
fab selon tout ça fonctionne c'est un
pas que voilà il ya un fait divers assez
colossal mais c'est un fait divers
derrière il ya un vainqueur médiatique
du feu de dieu
et qu'est-ce qu'on répond la loi et
l'école la loi et les golfeurs si vous
reprenez le matin ou du président de la
république il est relancé à deux
reprises pour dire loi tant qu'il dit
palois on lui dit et loi est une loi est
la loi et il finit par dire en ces
matières et doit être probablement
nécessaire moi je pense que en effet
l'essentiel c'est d'abord les comportant
mais que là pour le coup chacun est
impliquée par je vous racontais
l'histoire parce que c'est l'histoire
que je raconterai à ma fille et que je
raconterai quatre secondes à ma petite
fille qui est une femme tout à fait
ministre sens normal du terme tout à
fait contre toutes ces choses là mais
qui trouve que ça devient un peu
délirant ce qu'on fait là dessus qui dit
sauf dans quelques situations
particulières en effet de pouvoir très
dur et d'infériorité très dur ce qu'il
faut apprendre aux femmes cs défendent
et moi un jour il ya un type
j'avais beau sein des gros seins ma
ville et ma comme ça et elle m'a dit
gros camions et bien moi je vais le prix
média pour les couilles et je lui dis
minibus ouais moi je vais raconter de
belles histoires comme ça et je vais
dire à mes enfants et aux autres
allaient quand on vous fait un truc
allez faites lui le coût du minibus et
ça c'est une contribution au moins aussi
important que allait faire une demi
heure de cours sur le sujet je vivrai
pas même quelques chiffres sur ce sujet
c'est le sondage va paraître demain dans
le figaro sont achetés fait part au dos
que ça pour le figaro et france info une
femme sur deux a déjà été victime de
seulement sexuelle ou d'agression
sexuelle 80% des français sont
favorables au projet de loi pour
verbaliser le harcèlement sexuel de rue
projet de loi qui date est antérieure à
la faire siffler non pardon ça qu'on
peut alors ça on leur demandait ce que
s'il fait siffler ses vassaux explain
experts et toujours pour le côté grand
déballage et d'un fait divers ou 57 %
des français approuvent l'initiative
hashtag balances ton port oui moi je
dois dire que même pour mettre un peu de
couleur positive c'est qu'au niveau des
étudiants je suis d'accord avec moi
olivier duhamel me niveau des étudiants
je trouve que les relations entre les
sexes ont particulier je trouve
particulièrement apaisé il
particulièrement agréable en fait on a
l'impression que tout de même il ya une
génération qui a appris certaines choses
je pense que on parle là plutôt de
difficultés sociales et aussi de
certains quartiers de certaines
difficultés évidemment mais que
globalement j'ai besoin que tu as une
génération qui est par rapport à la
génération j'étais étudiant est beaucoup
plus respectueuse des films poser la
question de la mixité c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet un peu annexes fin pas un
ex mes voisins la question s'est posée
dans les quartiers difficiles avec des
enseignants des parents d'élèves qui
disait il faudrait peut-être mieux
séparer les filles et les garçons
maintenant
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque de
l'adolescence enfin les profs disent que
c'est souvent plus commode d'avoir les
filles d'un côté des garçons de l'autre
que dans l'état ça pose pas de problème
que dans les années que même à partir de
la seconde première séance par m au
milieu c'est un peu plus compliqué parce
qu'il ya une différence de maturité et
c'est non mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que quelle mais quelle régression
ici je veux dire on a mis combien de
combien de siècles à faire des lycées
mixte des faits c'est maintenant on
ferait si elle saisit enfin c'est pour
ça que je suis pas je ne dis pas qu'il
faut généraliser ça je me dis que si ça
donc de parents le souhaitent après tout
pourquoi pas ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que et là je rejoins ce que vous
dites c'est que c'est à ce fait divers
c'est bien évidemment considérable et un
peu aussi un peu l'arbre qui cache la
forêt c'est à dire que les malheurs bien
réel et absolument abominable et
scandaleux qui arrive aux actrices sont
tout à fait condamnable ce qui se passe
en entreprise est tout à fait
condamnable et dans cette situation de
pouvoir est évidemment très condamnable
et intolérable après la pesée des
politiques me semble-t-il
en france c'est quand même davantage ce
qu'on attend en vain de parler la demi
mot c est ce dans certains quartiers où
les femmes ne peuvent plus pénétrer ne
veux pas entrer dans les bistrots où dès
qu'elle passe dans la rue elles elles se
font construire ça c'est quand même ça
là pour le coup on est dans l'ordre du
politique mais c'est pour la raison avec
sea breeze et même si vous avez raison
sur le fond qu'il s'agit pas de la même
chose mais c'est pour la même raison que
j'ai une résistance à l'idée de faire
des classes deux garçons des classes de
fouilles parce que tu d'accord qu'on
soit c'est pas une chose que d'interdire
à défi d'aller dans un café mais c'est
quand même rentrer dans ses droits de la
bonne solution c'est de séparer et moi
je ne suis pas pour la séparation et on
a un bon exemple pour un contre exemple
vous savez quelle est la ville du monde
la plus dangereuse pour les femmes c'est
le caire on peut pas dire qu'on est la
mixité dans l'enseignement en egypte
passent à la clé soeur de la victime
nombre d'enseignements
ni mon avis c'est pas le grison de la
mixité dans les cours pour la peine je
veux dire des cultures est bon alors on
va le dire ça va être ça fait plaisir
bédié parce qu il attend que je dise
donc je vais le dire il ya des cultures
et la relation homme-femme notamment
dans l'islam est pas exactement un
modèle d'égalité et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui les quartiers dont nous
parlons en parlant de quartier très
pudiquement ce sont des quartiers où il
ya une forte proportion de musulmans on
le sait ça ça pose un problème politique
les fameux bistrot les femmes mon père
avait pas le droit d'aller le fameux
quartier de la chapelle pajol où on a
envoyé des missions exploratoires pour
tout le monde sait que ce sont des
populations d'origine étrangère qui qui
qui s'en prennent aux femmes qu'il faut
encourager toutes les femmes normales
mais bien sûr ça comment mais bien sûr
donc ça c'est absolument quand on jette
un regard jour il ya un terrain très
politiquement correct j'ai découvert
c'est la méditerranée isation de la
société pour écrire c'est comme
l'écriture inclusive avec ce mot n'a
aucune chance
seul mot n'a aucune chance parce qu'ils
voient c'est la chose qui m'importe plus
que le mauvais voyez par exemple les
ânes dit je suis professeur en grande
section de maternelle maternelle et je
vois certains comportements qui ne sont
pas des comportements d'enfants
expression ges trois petits points et
qui ne peut venir que des parents c'est
demi métis dit elle josh je suis
d'accord avec alexis braisé l'école
c'est le lieu du savoir pas du savoir
vivre et 2 mais en tout cas
d'abord de la meilleure solution du
savoir et nicole barbade moi l'essentiel
c'est l'éducation
en amont nous quand même que dans notre
bonne vieille école nostalgie qui avait
des leçons de morale donc on ne
s'occupait pas seulement du sa mort y
avait aussi le comportement et le
civisme mais sans que ce soit l'objet
d'un court et je croisais brède sûr on
était d'accord c'est que évidemment les
enseignants doivent veiller en général
le fond à ce que les comportements
soient des comportements respectueux et
pas accès ne pas accepter d'être très
difficile pour eux un parce qu'il a plu
c'est difficile sur la possibilité
ne sont pas forcément tout à fait
soutenu par l'institution alors l'école
en espagne et en catalogne
je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il en
est sur le plan des comportements mais
en tout cas le bras alors soufflé la
mois soyez charitable avec des grandes
parties du grande partie du sentiment
indépendantiste catalan est liée à la
politique éducative de la généralité qui
a véritablement cathala 10 et
l'enseignement depuis une trentaine
d'années et on a les générations
indépendantiste qui en sont sortis vous
voyez que nous gérons d'après un
spécialiste des pays-bas vous êtes un
spécialiste de la catalogne entre madrid
et barcelone le bras de fer continue
l'autonomie pourrait être de la
catalogne pourrait être suspendu dès
samedi
réunis à bruxelles les dirigeants de
l'union européenne regarde cette
escalade avec inquiétude mais pourront
ils rester encore longtemps de simples
observateurs à son arrivée à bruxelles
le président français a parlé de
nécessaire message d'unité autour de
l'espagne on le regarde sera marquée par
un message d'unité et d'unité autour de
nos états membres face aux crises ils
peuvent connaître unités
tour de l'espagne et unité aussi très
forte dans la discussion du break 6
olivier duhamel cette position de
principe c'est une affaire espagnol ça
nous regarde pas les taux nabeul encore
longtemps
oui franchement je pense pas que ce soit
à l'union européenne de construire si
tenté qu'il soit possible une médiation
on reproche déjà beaucoup beaucoup à
l'europe de s'occuper de choses qui ne
sont pas de son ressort parfois à tort
parfois à raison et sa seule c'est la
notion de thor et de raisons dépend
selon les points de vue évidemment mais
on peut imaginer des ong des instances
extérieures au conflit on peut imaginer
l'église de catalogne et l'espagne on
peut imaginer beaucoup de solutions mais
l'europe n'a pas pour vocation à venir
résoudre un problème interne à un pays
en train de se disloquer et d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière l'europe
elle a dit ce qu'elle avait à dire ce
qui d'ailleurs a beaucoup par angers
madrid
elle a dit qu'il était hors de question
que la catalogne haderer à l'union
européenne sans reprendre reste dans
l'union européenne sans engager tout un
processus d'adhésion
évidemment prostitution qui voit aucune
chance d'aboutir puisque il faut
l'unanimité donc vérité c'est que tous
les états européens soutiennent quand
même le point de vue de madrid dans
cette affaire parce qu'ils n'ont pas du
tout envie d'importer ce genre de
problématique chez eux
et puis parce qu'il ya quand même une
question légale et que l'europe doit
maintenir la légalité de la courbe des
constitutions et d aider scrutin donc
voilà et je pense que l'europe peut
guère peut difficilement s'engager parce
que madrid de prendre vraiment très très
mal parce que pour eux c'est c'est
impossible d'accepter que dès que les
étrangers viennent régler cette question
parce que je ne peux absolument pas même
son doigt dans cet engrenage
parce qu'après si c'est ça il ya plus
d'offres parce que de façon à ce moment
là mais madrid récusera l'europe
et puis ensuite la lombardie et la
vénétie il ya un référendum très bientôt
pour obtenir et donc voilà déjà l'europe
avec à 27 marche pas si bien que ça mais
face
sa quarantaine ça ça veut dire que si
l'europe l'europe est obligé de
reconnaître que les que les états et
surtout pas se mêler de donc se poser en
médiateur entre deux personnes c'est
reconnaître dans une certaine mesure
leur égalité et donc dire ça c'est s'est
créé les conditions de l'explosion a
créé les conditions d'explosion d'europe
donc l'europe
absolument pas le faire mais si on se
projette à samedi lundi prochain
la situation qu'on ne connaît pas ben là
je veux dire là je me courageusement me
gêne alors qualité d'historien ça c'est
du passé pas de l'avenir
je trouve qu'on est dans un jeu de poker
menteur la 1 + 1 ces jeux des carnets
demande en ce sens a déclaré tout en la
déclarant je te mets un ultimatum mais
je respecte pas le type comme je te
renvoie la balle par une lettre on est
véritablement dans un jeu très ouvert
un jeu dangereux most dangerous game
peut-être et tous peuvent tout peut
déraper ainsi un incident majeur par
exemple un des morts par exemple on
aurait là un cocktail explosif donc
et quand on connaît aussi la situation
c'est très intéressant vous avec le
gouvernement catalan refuse de de faire
de nouvelles élections ce que propose
madrid et moi ce qui me semble tout de
même la voix la démocratie faire de
nouvelles élections me paraît quand même
toujours une bonne chose quand les
élections sont régulières et sereine je
parle pas d'un d'élections venezuela en
l'occurrence mais quand on fait de
nouvelles élections
je crois que ce serait la solution et
non pas une médiation en effet mais
comme par hasard le gouvernement catalan
a refusé car il sait que sa majorité
très fragile notamment comme l'a rappelé
olivier duhamel parce que il n'ya plus
de possibilité européenne pour la
catalogne
or de l'espagne et ça ça fait réfléchir
non seulement madrid saeed madrid mais
ça fait réfléchir
énormément de catalan je pense rien
moins que les jours passant le camp
indépendantiste et plus des mondes sont
en train de perdre des mails d'une part
ils ont perdu beaucoup quand et où
l'accumulation décisions économiques de
changer les sièges de conseillers
généraux banques et entreprises en
france fonctionne et donc on a fait
prendre conscience de conséquences
très très mauvaises pour la catalogne en
premier d'indépendance alors que l'idée
c'était si on est indépendant sera plus
obligé de faire la péréquation fiscale
pour l'extra badoer l'avion va
s'enrichir et que là ils commencent à
comprendre à s'appauvrir
et la deuxième chose c'est que les
tergiversations de plus des monos - la
force drogue dit allez un peu fort en
terme de répression
mais la force de la rue c'est la
constance de sa ligne c'est à dire c'est
illégal c'était légitime je suis garant
de l'unité du peuple d'espagne et jeu
utiliserait tous les moyens pour la
faire respecter
on comprend ce que ça veut dire et c'est
clair plus des moniteurs déclare une
apaisante
puis la suspend puis donnant des
négociations puis retire c'est à dire
c'est la confusion 455 dont on est tous
les spécialistes et que effectivement il
ya pas le souhaitez mais des morts dans
la rue se passe quoi on peut peut-être
vous allez peut-être un peu vite en
mettant une relation directe donc
l'application de l'article 155 y ait des
morts dans la rue on peut décider que on
prend le contrôle à la place de la
région et du gouvernement régional et du
parlement régional des décisions
concernant la 4 l oeil on peut dit c'est
éventuellement qu'on arrête les gens qui
s'y opposent
on est quand même capable d'arrêter des
gens sont habitués quand on sait faire
son travail à peu près correctement
d'ailleurs jusqu'ici il n'y a pas eu
mort d'homme et donc de dramatisons pas
complètement la prise du contrôle par
madrid
il faut juste se faire à peu près bien
et éviter d'une part de tuer des gens
évidemment et d'autre part des matraques
et des vieilles dames mais bon si on est
vite ça ça va moi j'ai le sentiment que
les indépendantistes ont perdu la partie
je m'en réjouis parce qu'ils sont pas
allées assez vite s'il avait emballé la
machine après le week-end élections de
répression etc
c'était l'émotion est là effectivement
les juges et des quinze jours qui ont
passé qui a permis à madrid de faire de
faire dire à l'europe que l'europe ne
l'accepterai pas
la catalogne est pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
ont attendu au fond c'est parce qu'ils
sont divisés
c'est parce que le référendum est un
déchet quand vous fais quarante deux
pour cent de participation de là excusez
moi mais le référendum en france sur
l'indépendance l'algérie c'est 75 % de
participation
le référendum des algériens sur
l'indépendance c'est 78 pour se départir
90 % du ca change les catalans sont très
divisés et y en a eues nous semble-t-il
d'une grosse moitié contre
l'indépendance le camp indépendantiste
est lui-même très divisés parce que les
adventices ya des gauchistes le spectre
est plus d'un an gros des centristes
qu'ils en ont marre de payer pour les
autres mais qui soutient qui sont
l'incarnation des milieux d'affaires et
c'est cela ils veulent pas du tout
sortir de l'euro ou à partir de l'europe
et donc dès qu'ils ont vu ça oui comment
ça se passe aux tirs et des flûtes et
donc du coup plus je demande pouvait
plus dire pouvaient plus accéder
donc soit il fallait le faire tout de
suite et est finalement rajoy me
semble-t-il
il a assez bien joué on peut discuter de
la question du week-end du premier
week-end électoral où il a connu très
fort mais depuis il avance avec méthode
insee de rien et les autres
l'ajac fonce dans 21 alexis que si le
peuple catalan était massivement comme
si ils étaient allés voter à 80% et
qu'ils avaient voté oui à 66% et bien là
c'était beaucoup plus difficile de
l'empêcher et ils pouvaient pour
prévenir tout de suite indépendance mais
que je le répète 6 catalans sur dix soit
en n'allant pas voter soi ou pour une
petite mort les internautes et nous a
refusé d'exprimer un désir
d'indépendance
ben voila si vous voulez c'est difficile
de faire la dépendance concis sur vis de
votre propre peuple n'en veut pas et que
le peuple donc elle vous fait partir
veut pas avancer quand même dans la
dialectique si on réfléchi parce que
plus on a dit si madrid suspend notre
autonomie alors on déclarera notre
indépendance mais aujourd'hui donc on
peut renverser le raisonnement et si
madrid maintien autonomie alors il y
aura peut-être pas de déclaration
d'indépendance on voit bien que les
indépendantistes aujourd'hui ont peur de
perdre l'essentiel ont peur de perdre
l'essentiel c'est à dire comme une
autonomie qui est très grande autonomie
de leur région
le talent est aussi le pouvoir le
gréement plus braves gens voient donc
donc
j'accorde champ pour quelques arbres
quand même assez bien manoeuvré parce
que là on voit qu'il ya eu un mouvement
malgré tout dans ce jeu de poker il ya
déjà un changement de position des
acteurs et bien merci à tous les quatre
merci aussi à marouane mehadji je vous
propose de regarder quelques images de
danielle darrieux qui s'était un peu
aujourd'hui après gisèle casadesus elle
aussi centenaire jean rochefort claude
rich une génération d'acteurs qui nous
quitte
restez sur figaro life dans un instant
un focus un focus à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale des statistiques et
cette info culte
on y revient sur les femmes et les
hommes dans l'union européenne et
notamment les différences hommes femmes
en matière de rémunération les femmes
gagnent 16,3 pour cent de moins que les
hommes dans l'union européenne c'est ce
qu'on va apprendre dans un instant avec
armelle boeing et ariane le coeur merci
à tous et à demain pour un nouveau point
de vue
[Musique]